ismael dibujo una copia de escala del
siguiente cuadrilátero uso un factor de
escala menor a 1 hoy podría ser la
longitud del lado que corresponde con el
segmento ade que es este y que mide 16
unidades en el dibujo original en la
copia a escala del cuadrilátero si el
factor de escala es menor a 1 entonces
el dibujo a escala tendrá este lado con
una longitud menor a 16 unidades y el
resto del cuadrilátero estará dibujado
con el mismo factor de escala es decir
el dibujo resultante puede verse algo
así como lo que estoy dibujando a mano
aquí lo importante es darnos cuenta de
que si el factor de escala es menor a 1
entonces este lado de acá será menor a
16 unidades vemos las opciones y nos
piden elegir tres de ellas pausa en el
vídeo y traten de elegir tres opciones
que coincidan con una escala cuyo factor
sea menor a uno bueno tenemos que ver
las opciones que sean menores a 16
unidades las tres primeras opciones son
menores a 16 y son las únicas menores a
16 esta de aquí es menor a 16 este es
menor a 16 y ésta también es menor a 16
de 32 unidades corresponde a un factor
de escala de 2 y la opción de 64
unidades corresponde a un factor de
escala de 4 así que confirmamos que
estas tres opciones son las correctas
con esto terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo